first of all America needs to believe
that everyone deserves a first-rate
education and I don't believe America
has even if we say we believe that we
haven't put our money where our mouth is
we have drastic funding in equities and
in certain areas where you know a poor
school district gets the shorter end of
the stick when it comes to education
funding and resources we don't pay
teachers enough in general we don't
treat teachers as though they're an
important profession we they're all any
number of reasons why education is poor
in America and part of it I think is a
result of some parents not putting
enough emphasis on education in their
own homes I grew up in a family where
education was was hyper important but I
think there are a lot of families that
don't stress it as much as they should
and so part of the responsibility lies
with the parents but overall I think as
a society we have we have made education
too much of a free market system where
if you have money if you have resources
your kids are going to get a good
education if you don't then they
probably won't and as long as that's the
case then there can't be equality of
opportunity because certain kids are
just not going to have the opportunities
that they should in order to even up the
playing field for them to maximize their
potential and we need that and then
there's also many factors I think that
that play into it and in the black
community especially black men there's I
think there's a certain level of despair
nihilism that they don't have the belief
that education is going to pay off for
them and I think there's enough of that
that encourages them to find other ways
to make money and crime often ends up
being one of those ways and because they
don't see the light at the end of the
tunnel because they don't have the optic
ism to believe that they can do
something legitimately and legally and
be successful then they resort to other
means and drug trade and all these
things that are certain young man get
caught up and a lot of it as a result of
unemployment despair and and and just a
lack of optimism in their communities
and I think education will go a long way
toward helping address that but there's
a myriad number of cultural issues that
we have to deal with as well and part of
it just starts within the families
stressing education stressing the
importance of having parents and
extended family that support and care
for the family and care for young people
and all those things are important
you